for me what we did is we got I got
expelled and then I think my mom was
just took things into her own hands and
then put me in military school holy and
then so when I got kicked out of the
military
school
[Music]
like so a Texas high school basketball
player beat up a coach after being
benched for poor Sportsman good for him
sick beat his
ass that's right he was facing um he he
got benched he's facing suspension and
and his coach is like hey dude you have
bad Sports and [__] you got to stop
doing this and so he just unloads on the
coach and just beats the [__] out of him
yeah they say basketball players are
soft but not this [__] guy not this
guy shut up coach yeah well I mean he
just ruined his future right like he
he's like you can't play anymore cuz of
bad sportsmanship but he's like how am I
supposed to [__] make it to the
Lakers if I don't play yeah and he goes
you're [__] up my future so I have to
[__] you up for [__] up my future
yeah do you think it's bad sportsmanship
to beat up your coach or no not if he
[__] cuz he's not technically in the
game at that moment yeah he's not your
coach anymore so he's not really a
sportsman at all so this is outside of
that got it cuz you can't be a
professional bench warmer you ever see
LeBron James he's always yelling at the
coach dude always he's always [__]
on him he just [__] screaming and the
the refs he's always begging for [__]
penalties yeah yeah oh watching him beg
and beg and
beg crazy oh yeah yeah yeah I do wish
players socked up fans more yeah you
know the ones that talking [__] all day
and then the [__] a 69ine dude comes
up to you and just [__] whs in your
face they say some rude [__] like I'm
going [__] kill your family type [__]
what was that moment that happened with
the Pacers that's like historical or
something with oh the Mal of the palace
yes you guys remember that Ron arest oh
yeah that's when Ron arst went into the
[__] fan I me the stadium and started
knocking apparently he punched the wrong
guy right jumped into the dance that's
wild dude that's good sports but then
that's when that's when you see true
athleticism cuz you know on the court
everyone's athletic everyone's [__]
610 or whatever the [__] so it kind of
like moves together then when you see
one of them decide to like go out of
bounds and fly into the bleachers and
you see regular people move like all
slow motion he's
like bam we like oh my [__] god
really see the difference right
especially with his legs his legs step
over the rows like that yeah cuz they
make Steve look short yeah they punch
past four rows I'm like dude I would
watch more of that
yeah some guys yelling at LeBron like
just two years ago and LeBron was like
actually yelling back into the stance
yeah yeah they'll they'll yell stuff
like I hope your kid dies in a car
accident like some CRA but that gets you
that gets you banned from games right
does it sometimes it doesn't sometimes
they let them they like nowadays I've
seen recently where like LeBron James or
a player will be like he's the guy he's
the guy talking [__] to me and scored
him out yeah but like it's just like
especially if you're Jack Nicholson and
you have all got like first pro they're
not going to kick you out yeah you spent
too much money dang they be talking mad
[__] Ron Artest running into the stands
to attack Michael Ryan who he believed
threw a cup at him and then apparently
it was actually the guy to his left oh
oh that's that's so funny hey you got
the wrong guy imagine you're that guy
you're like oh Ron Essa is coming over
to me Ron Ron what's up dude he's like
[__] you just randomly decides to [__]
you up so he's probably not that good of
a sportsman if he missed no that's true
doesn't have a good eye true went went
to the wrong one and then he changes his
name to World Peace yeah world peace
that is that is such a funny concept
though like when you're in school and
you get in trouble for like talking or
something you're already in trouble so
you just might as well keep talking it
feels like that you know like it's a
very immature response of like dude I'm
already out of the game for bad
sportsmanship me prove to you how bad I
am already proing exactly the quote by
the coach is amazing right he says uh so
he benches the guy for sportsmanship and
then he gets his ass beat by him and
then he he talks to the news and he when
he's talking to the news he says I would
have never thought in a million years
this would happen to me with this
particular kid what wow so is that
supposed to be like he's a good kid I
don't know why he would do this so it's
a kid that flipped out it's not a kid
that has like consistent bad Sportsman
Behavior maybe that's what it is but
like that's weird being a bad Sportsman
on the court might be like Oh I'm
talking [__] to the other players I'm
like talking to the ref but like
fighting your coach is all different
[__] bag of worms bro that's just
personal maybe he meant like never in a
million years did I think I'd get my ass
beat by this high school kid maybe maybe
it's that take I wonder if it was during
the game was it during the game it was
yeah oh [__] oh D so everybody saw it
damn dude that's pretty embarrassing
jeez that wild uh he says that he he
said that he just wanted the kid to cool
off but then he told him um and he told
the coach not to speak to him after that
and then immediately so it's immediately
after the game which they won um he he
like gets on the coach's ass and starts
wait they won oh because he couldn't
play okay yeah yeah yeah but that means
benching him was a good call if they won
after he got benched how come the coach
couldn't be him up was the coach like
5et I think he was just surprised well
that's the thing too what is your
protocol when a kid is trying to beat
you up beat his ass [__] yeah I don't
know have you seen these high school
kids yeah like if a a kid who's like
your size is like trying to beat you up
what do you do but most Asian parents
are smaller than their kids and they'll
[__] them up and if they can't do it
they'll call for backup and Auntie Uncle
and grandma would [__] jump you dude
do you just like try to restrain them I
think no you choke them you do this
thing were they yeah oh
yeah you know basketball players if you
were a teacher in a in a Samoan High
School good luck all right they sent you
over to Samoa because they're like oh we
need a substitute teacher it's a middle
school everyone's
6'2 and you're sitting there and
everyone's talking going [__] wild
and you go up to this boy you're like
hey settle down and he goes make me what
do you do
I start putting on hockey
pads and then then take them
off what I would do is probably try to
figure out what what they really like
and so if they try to they like food
figure out what they really like i' be
like what did you say to me and then
here here's a cupcake you know cuz
light's like cuz light's like a cartoon
yeah that's how it works he like make me
and you go here's a cupcake and he goes
ooh like hey hey calm down calm down I
do remember having the realization I
think it was in Middle School when like
I think in elementary school everyone's
kind of like similar creatures and then
in middle school all of a sudden
[__] like there's me who's like
410 like 70 lb and then another dude
that's already like 510 Duncan and then
you're like what is the teacher going to
say to restrain him this guy could
literally do whatever he wants and like
he'll hop the fence faster than you can
chase him or anything I'm like this is
like the power Dynamic is way different
now and that's like pre puberty yeah
imagine High School the 510 guy that's
dunking is [__] 64 280 and you're
like what the [__] what do a teach like
you just have like how do you coach kids
like that you tell the principal you go
to someone higher up princip no no no
you go I no jurisdiction yeah yeah so
the the kid's being expelled really yeah
he's no longer going to school there
he's probably never playing ever again
cuz all the other schools going to be
like dude that's the kid that beat up a
coach but if he was really good he will
get picked up that's true
so even though he's oh dang as somebody
who's been expelled from schools what
happens when you've been expelled so
many times like where do you go to
school I didn't get expelled that much
there go they they typically rotate you
in the district that's a sick ass quote
so I went to I only went I got so the
first one was um yeah in the in the
district what they usually do is number
one you get expelled from one school
then you have to go to like a
districtwide meeting and then they'll
meet with the principes of the other
schools and they go okay cool bring them
in and then when you go to that school
if you get expelled then I think they
probably put you in the continuation
school oh so that's full of kids who
have been exposed and then after that I
don't know what happens I've never gone
past that uh for me for me what we did
is we got I got expelled and then I
think my mom was just took things into
her own hands and then put me in
military school holy and so when I got
kicked out of the military
school like it was kind of like a
blessing in disguise because I got to go
back to the same district because it
wasn't getting kicked out like if I got
kicked out at Keele and Al Hamra they'd
be like what do we do with this guy
right but I think it was because I got
kicked out of SOS went to the military
school I kicked out of citos and I ended
up in Mar kep so it's like almost like a
fresh start every time so you go to a
different District yeah you can see the
world yeah
hey he's on
tour wow man that kind of makes sense
though yeah that's about right and I was
talking to J about it I was like do you
have you ever met your superintendent
she was like no who's that I was like
every Super I met every superintendent
of every District I've been to wait
which school did you graduate from then
I and then graduate from K oh okay nice
what the [__] man dude as soon as you
walked out of there you know they're
like
[Music]
got